[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's something we've
noticed you may have noticed it too
all of a sudden pretty much every
powerful person in the country is
talking about something called democracy
democracy our sacred democracy
you hear that word everywhere from the
atlantic to npr to the new yorker
magazine and nbc news in between
democracy defines the year 2022 the way
that groovy defined 1968. all the cool
kids are saying it liz cheney has
decided her life's mission is now to
defend democracy jim acosta has a new
cnn show in which he uses the word
democracy the way some people use
prepositions in every sentence
tomorrow at 2 p.m eastern there's a zoom
webinar on democracy which you're
welcome to attend in case you haven't
heard enough about it already every left
of center midwit on twitter will be
there all of them will be fretting about
the future of democracy
pretty amusing it's easy to make fun of
an event like that and of course you
have a moral obligation to david frum
bloviates about democracy insert joke
here
but actually if we're being honest about
it you should be a little worried about
the state of our democracy how is our
democracy doing
well let's see another way to describe
democracy is popular representation
that's a synonym when the government
does what citizens want it to do you
have a democracy and when it doesn't you
don't you no longer have a free country
that is ruled by its people
so what kind of system do we have it's
easy to know you find out what citizens
care about and then you compare those
concerns to what the people who run the
government say they care about if you've
got a functioning democracy there should
be a fairly precise overlap in a
democratic system leaders try very hard
to speak for their voters that's the
whole point of the government
so let's apply that test to the united
states of america what do our leaders
care about we know the answer because
they tell us constantly our leaders care
about equity and climate change they
care about trans rights police brutality
the deadly insurrection of january 6th
mandatory vaccinations more h-1b visas
for indian tech workers and above all at
the moment defending our closest ally
ukraine from russian aggression and of
course they care about third wave
academic feminism that's deeply
important to them
watch as the most famous democrat in
congress gives us an impromptu tutorial
on instagram about the connection
between cosmetics and the patriarchy
there are studies that show that women
who wear makeup or regularly wear like a
a decent amount of makeup kind of show
up to the office and glam also make more
money
and so
at that point it stops being these
calculations and decisions stop being
about
choice
and they start being about
patriarchy
we
live in systems
that were largely built for the
convenience of men and often times were
designed
with the subjugation of women
and queer people in mind
give that lady an msnbc show sorry mika
i wear makeup because i'm oppressed me
me me me me now the shorthand
description of that is narcissism which
in the end is the defining concern of
our leaders above all they're interested
in themselves if you work in the media
or have multiple college degrees chances
are you're pretty good at making it all
about you
you is what you care about most
what does the rest of america care about
once again we don't have to guess about
that we've got a huge amount of public
opinion polling on that subject you're
seeing the results right now from a
recent gallup survey on your screen
at the top of that list you'll see
government incompetence the economy the
cost of living and immigration
well that's weird this looks completely
different from the list that joe biden
might have made
equity climate change transgenderism
mandatory vaxxes january 6 ukraine
those trends be pretty unimportant to
most americans fact some of those issues
are at the very bottom of the list
but how can that be
if global climate change is the most
imminent existential crisis of our time
then why don't voters seem concerned
about it
we don't know but they're definitely not
concerned about it instead americans are
very worried about inflation and crime
as it happens and this tells you
everything those are the two topics the
white house has dismissed recently as
irrelevant and dumb the white house
isn't at all worried about inflation and
crime
hmm
that doesn't sound like democracy
here's the white house press secretary
taking some time off from her junior
year at oberlin to speak to her fellow
undergrads at something called pod safe
america about how rising crime rates are
actually an invention of those racists
at fox news
right now just to give you a sense so
cnn pentagon as many as 8 500 u.s troops
on heightened alert okay true same on
msnbc cnbc is doing their own thing
about the market and then on fox is
janine pirro talking about soft on crime
consequences i mean what
what does that even mean right um so
there's an alternate universe on some
uh coverage what's scary about it is a
lot of people watch that and they they
think that the president isn't doing
anything to address
people's safety
so what are your kids getting shot have
to do with ukraine nothing dumbo you're
living in an alternate universe
that's jen saki's position you have to
be delusional to think crime was a
problem in this country unless you
happen to be in georgetown last night
around 6 45 pm if you were there you may
have seen a man shot to death outside
georgetown cupcakes that's just off m
street and the funny thing is that's not
too far from where jensaki lives but did
gensake acknowledge that happened of
course she didn't
noticing the collapse of your
civilization is racist even when it's
happening just down the street look away
jensaki look away
and whatever you do don't go to
baltimore
baltimore is a major american city it's
only about 40 miles from where gensake
lives it's one of the worst places in
the western hemisphere it's a little bit
of haiti in the mid-atlantic baltimore
is exactly what happens when you apply
gensake's ideas to governing
baltimore is a city run by people who
fervently believe in the equity agenda
and consider gender studies a legitimate
academic discipline
in baltimore pretty much everyone in
charge is black yet it's a matter of
religious faith that the main thing
holding the city back is white racism in
other words everybody with power in
baltimore agrees with gensake
so it's an entirely fair question to ask
hey gen saki what do you think of
baltimore how did the city get that way
you claim to care so deeply about
african americans you never stopped
talking about that and yet here is one
of the biggest black majority cities in
the united states tens of thousands of
black people who live in baltimore are
in misery because their kids keep
getting murdered
last year baltimore's murder rate was
higher than it is in el salvador and
honduras now those are countries the
state department tells us to quote avoid
due to crime
so it's fair to say things are
incredibly violent in baltimore they
have been for a long time and yet under
joe biden somehow they've gotten even
worse in baltimore here's a local news
report from today
the hugging and crying
sounds of sorrow outpouring of emotions
over the killing of a loved one 36
homicides in the first month this year
in baltimore city with only two arrests
one for a deadly shooting the other a
stabbing death
36 murders
in 31 days that's the deadliest january
in baltimore in nearly 50 years and
remember 50 years ago baltimore was
almost twice as big as it is now half
the city's left so baltimore is far
worse off than it has ever been in its
history and it's not just murders drug
crimes are up dramatically you might not
know that because they're not being
prosecuted anymore
last spring the local city attorney a
george soros puppet called marilyn mosby
announced she would no longer prosecute
low-level drug crimes so arrests
plummeted but drug trafficking exploded
here's what it looks like
car cameras caught what appears to be
one of those open-air drug deals
happening in broad daylight near the
edmondson village shopping center it's
an issue we've been hearing about in
neighborhoods citywide throughout the
summer it comes after city state's
attorney marilyn mosby stopped
prosecuting certain drug crimes in the
city including drug possession a major
policy shift that some believe have left
the issue to only flourish
for that black people don't want laws to
be enforced that's her view that's the
view of everyone she knows
but what did policies like that do to
baltimore well they turned a once
beautiful city into a slum
according to a report by fox 45 in
baltimore public school administrators
have instructed the police to stop
arresting students for committing crimes
and that would include serious offenses
from burglary to assault so the cops did
stop arresting kids the number of
students arrested in baltimore schools
has dropped by 98 percent in the last
decade that's good on paper but it turns
out ignoring crime is not the same as
stopping crime
schools in baltimore got so bad that
kids stopped learning anything
watch this report and ask yourself what
is baltimore going to look like in 20
years
in reading
628 patterson high school students took
the test
484 of them or 77 percent
tested at an elementary school reading
level that includes
71 high school students who are reading
at a kindergarten level and 88 students
reading at a first grade level another
45 are reading at a second grade level
just 12 students tested at patterson
high school were reading at grade level
that comes out
to less than two percent
so the kids can't read they're
illiterate what does their future look
like what does baltimore's future look
like what does the country's future look
like how are they going to participate
in our society
you wouldn't know any of this was
happening by looking at the official
graduation numbers because last year
baltimore announced that students will
graduate from high school even if they
failed their courses
baltimore's so-called chief academic
officer that would be a harvard educated
bureaucrat called joan dabrowski
announced that this policy was designed
to quote avoid the punitive approach of
failing students
okay
but somebody is failing students in
baltimore somebody in fact is failing
the entire city and you have to ask
yourself
who would that be
you'd like to ask jen saki who do you
blame for baltimore did white men do
this to baltimore was it the patriarchy
was it structural racism that caused all
those murders do you agree with pete but
a judge that klansmen urban planners put
the highways in the wrong place and
that's the real problem racist roads
or could it be that the real problem
with baltimore is something much more
obvious could it be that progressive
policies designed to quote lift up
marginalized communities in the end
destroyed those communities what's the
answer gensake
in a functioning democracy people like
gensake would have to tell us the answer
they would be required to live in
baltimore until they learned something
just as the people who wrecked
afghanistan probably ought to explain
what they've learned before they move on
to ukraine and russia that ought to be a
requirement
and in fact honestly you'd think that
people like this would welcome a chance
to reflect on what they've done they
have screwed up very badly they've hurt
the weakest among us for christians
that's the greatest sin but these people
aren't christians they worship only
themselves so they turn away
you can bet money that gensake rarely
goes to baltimore it's just too
depressing and it raises too many
questions instead jen saki and her
friends are planning their fun little
summer trips to bozeman or martha's
vineyard or east hampton or some other
remote and blindingly white outpost of
privilege
funny how that works
you wreck stuff and then you ignore it
this allows you to wreck more stuff
without feeling guilty
that's modern progressivism distilled to
18 words hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else